und wir begrüßen hier im studio bild
meinem chef philippe piatti als mit den
themen über die deutschland heute früh
spricht und eines davon philipp ist ein
bisschen seltsame löschaktion von
youtube was hat es damit auf sich ganz
genau also wir haben gestern erfahren
und auch berichtet dass youtube die
videoplattform mehrere videos der
künstler aktion alles auf dem tisch
gelöscht hat da sind diese künstler
videos interviews mit
regierungskritischen zum teil sehr
renommierten krone experten die eine
künstlergruppe um volker bruch wotan
wilke möhring und so weiter
veröffentlicht hat um sich mit dem zu
beschäftigen die ihrer meinung nach in
der korona krise zu kurz kam und da
wurde auch über meinungsfreiheit
gesprochen wurde über die fehler in der
inzidenz gesprochen und youtube hat
jetzt drei videos mindestens einfach
gelöscht und das hat auch auswirkungen
auf die zukunft dieses youtube kanals
sieben tage lang darf dort gerade erst
mal nichts hochgeladen werden und
übrigens auch nicht das neue video das
interview mit der ehemaligen
familienministerin
kristina schröder also dieses video kann
jetzt tagelang nicht hochgeladen werden
weil dieser kanal mit ihrer art sperre
belegt wurde die begründung für diese
sperre viele ja das ist total abstrakt
also youtube sagt der wirt angeblich
gegen irgendwelche standards verstoßen
da wird etwas über schutzimpfungen gegen
co wird behauptet behauptet was aber
nicht im einklang zu bringen sei mit der
whu und aber es wird nicht klar also ich
habe youtube gestern angefragt habe nach
klartext verlangt und gefragt was ist es
denn konkret welche aussage ist es dann
konkret an der sie sich stellen und da
kam bislang nichts zurück auch die
künstler wissen nicht warum diese videos
gelöscht wurden sie sprechen davon dass
ihre sich einfach stumm geschaltet
werden und gehen jetzt auch mit dem top
anwalt joachim steinhöfel der wirklich
expertenmeinung szabo kommt in diesen
mengen dioxin mit virtuellen welten weg
im gespräch da geht jetzt gegen youtube
vor und ist er auch relativ
zuversichtlich ich hab gestern mit ihm
gesprochen hat mir gesagt er ist absolut
fassungslos das ist eine ganz neue
dimension
das hier einfach wirklich interviews mit
experten zb mit mit einem mathematik
mathematik professor aus leipzig der
über incidents gesprochen hätte glasklar
aufgezeigt hat wurde die fehler der
berechnungen lagen also wirklich absolut
harmlose interviews sehr einfach
gestrichen werden du hast er stundenlang
diese videos die angeschaut auch genau
geguckt was da drin steckt wie
provokantes ist ob da irgendwelche
falschen fakten drin sind und so hast du
irgendwas gefunden was gefährlich ist
was eine löschaktion eventuell eben doch
rechtfertigt nein also ehrlich gesagt
ich konnte natürlich kein faktencheck
machen aber ein falscher fakt ist für
mich noch keine grundlage für eine
löschung ich glaube wenn man anfängt da
so drauf zu schauen wie was könnte man
etwas könnte eventuell nicht ganz
richtig sein er gut da kann ich youtube
aber eine ganze liste voller videos
schicken und zwar auch von der
bundesregierung auch von karl lauterbach
auch von jens spahn und von christian
drosten und wirklich von allen aber
youtube ist ja keine fakten check
plattform keine wahrheitskommission die
jetzt entscheidet was nun richtig und
was falsch ist und man kann über viele
dinge das sieht man bei youtube
vielleicht nicht so einfach auch
unterschiedlicher meinung sein und das
war toll immer ne würde die aktion ist
sowas immer ganz praktisch
unterschiedlicher meinung zu sagen gar
nicht mal so schlecht und ich frage mich
wenn ich so interviews sehe mit wirklich
renommierten experten und dann kommt
youtube und löscht das wer ist denn
youtube ist dass eine universität sind
ist das ein virologen gremium wester
sitzt sich diese youtube-videos alle
anschauen sagt ja aber dass dieses eine
von den 100 millionen die heute
hochgeladen wurden das löschen aber kann
man ja mal aufrufen ganz kurz filip also
lieber herr youtube wenn sie ruhig hören
heute melden sie sich derjenige der das
alles gelöscht hat jetzt wer hat sich
damit beschäftigt wer hat das gelöscht
melden sie sich einfach bei uns wir
können jede diskussion diskutieren im
studio gerne herzlich vielleicht für
morgen früh für morgen vormittag
internet eingeladen die herren von und
da natürlich von youtube für eine bunte
diskussion über meinungsvielfalt hier in
deutschland und im netz
[Musik]